they're still
fighting for breath in here 11 months
after the uk's first
coveted patients arrived in newcastle
it's still here
still framing our lives
well i've actually taken my retirement
but then came back
the eye department here is barbara's
second home
she had a heart attack 10 years ago came
back
and she's worked throughout covid i
don't feel like i'm old
i'm still quite happy working but it
just brings
it it makes you vulnerable um you know
when you are traveling on
public transport and it does because i
did worry that if i did get it
you know would i would i survive and to
hear that she would be getting the
vaccine on day one
was hard to take in feels like will you
want to talk to the factory tomorrow
i've got the golden ticket
this golden day brings hope after
immeasurable heartache
it really is a new dawn in this crisis
it has the power of course to transform
our lives but
also to alleviate the intense pressure
on our nhs they feel that most acutely
in intensive care the number of patients
with covid is still
falling but every frontline medic in
here
expects it to rise again after christmas
this is not the time to see what is it
that we can get away with this is not a
game of of just
um duck uncover you know this is a
a real important time for everybody
and in order to enjoy more christmases
together we need to
to just hang in there for this christmas
[Music]
really i felt quite vulnerable because i
wasn't in control
and normally in this room i'm in control
bob is a consultant in emergency care
but in march
he was a covered patient in this bed
and in a bad way if we have a bad
christmas because people are just
ignoring all the rules we will have a
terrible
third wave and a terrible time of the
year in january and february
when other viruses are rife as well
are you happy to proceed with this yes
yes very very happy yes
yes and so barbara had no hesitation
in using her golden ticket
all right yeah you're the envy of the
world
so it's unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable
kind of believe it don't think anything
ever has happened like this before to me
so
you know it's um i've had my life saved
once after having had the heart attack
and this feels like another exciting
time
no vaccine can undo the sacrifices we've
all made the people who've held this
front line
are pleading with us not to give up when
the way out
is now in sight tom parmenter sky news
newcastle